let's go next to our caller from the
832 area code who is calling today from
832. hello
yes it is who's this uh this is reuben
from
houston reuben from houston what's going
on
right so i had two questions and mostly
it's just to you know orient myself a
little better
or you know understand you know
expectations
so with uh with the death of the supreme
court justice
uh there's been a lot of uh alarm
sounding i'll say and i just
i just want to know like it appears
we won't be able to stop it or you know
we have very limited options
yeah but if if if
uh they do appoint a supreme court
justice
is it really i mean i know it's pretty
bad and it's a shame that it was
happening
but is it really um
that bad uh say if we
take the senate and
you know get the president elected it's
still pretty bad
it's two different things okay that's
the thing so so reuben it's two
different things
the things that are bad about a six to
three conservative court
are different things than what a
democratic senate can prevent
and so for example if you get a 6-3
conservative supreme court
you'll start to see a really strict
restrictions on abortion passed at the
state level which will be challenged
in local courts appealed to federal
courts
and ultimately to the supreme court and
the supreme court could
issue rulings which set new precedent
which dramatically clamps down
on abortion rights as an example that
has nothing to do with democrats taking
the senate you understand so we're
talking about
but taking the senate is of huge
importance
but the appointed for life
supreme court which could go 6-3
conservative
is a whole slate of problems that have
nothing to do with the senate
right right i mean i i i recognize that
it's just
it seems like i mean obviously
for it's just that we don't hear in the
media
when a supreme court decision really
affects anything
except for every once in a while i'm not
sure what else
like you know i don't know that i agree
with that i mean listen
i think maybe people don't pay attention
but if you look over the last
years you know very important rulings
with regard to
obamacare commerce related rulings that
affect how business is done stuff about
business discrimination
really important rulings about corporate
power i mean i think people don't
necessarily understand how those
decisions link to their everyday lives
it's just that it's just that you said
you only mentioned the abortion and that
that is something that i
i'm pro-pro-choice but
uh it's just i i guess i didn't think
about like
health care things like that yeah okay
uh so second question is um so i
i make the mistake of donating to like
um
presidential election campaigns like
like biden
i mean it's not really a mistake it's
just like now they're hounding me all
the time and
i'm getting ads for you know um
for donating to you know senators and
just people running against republicans
and i wanted to ask
is that actually helpful like how
how how much use is that
money gonna go towards uh you know
making the country a better place well
th those are two questions
is donating helpful to get people
elected the candidate who raises more
money tends to win all else being equal
so yeah it does help people get elected
whether they will improve the country
once elected is a much
more detailed and deep question that
probably exceeds our time today but yes
that money does help get people elected
by the way i've never donated to anybody
and i get the same ads
so i don't know how much of it is just
everybody's getting ads right now well
yeah i mean i guess if you just seem
politically involved
right that happens okay well uh
thank you very much uh for your answers
uh
and i really i really do think
uh you're doing a good thing here thank
you i appreciate the call thank you so
much
terrific to hear from you we are going
to go to a break my apologies i was not
able to take every phone call
but i do the best i can quick break back
after this